le marronnage est un phénomène défini
par la fuite des esclaves donc qui
cherchent à fuir les conditions
d'esclavagé les plantations
c'est un sujet qui a été étudiée du
point de vue historique à la réunion
depuis les années 1970
et depuis très récemment il commence à
étudier sous un angle totalement nouveau
qui est l'anglais vainqueur logique donc
il y avait deux fentes de marronnage
tout d'abord le petit marronnage qui
définit des fuites des fuites de petits
durée souvent quelques jours et puis il
ya eu le grand marronnage donc là des
fuites de très longue durée dans
lesquelles les marrons s'organiser en
bande et fuyez vers l'atelier de l'île
vers des zones très inaccessibles où il
pouvait être totalement dissimulé donc
c'est cette deuxième forme de marronnage
qui va nous intéresser
pour le pôle études archéologiques
puisque c'est celle ci qui va laisser
des traces tangibles dans le sol ou à la
surface du sol
l'intérêt de l'unc logis du marronnage à
la réunion est de combler un certain
nombre de lacunes documentaire on peut
voir dans les documents historiques donc
par par exemple on a très peu
d'informations sur le mode de vie de ces
esclaves fugitifs dans les théâtres et
lieux de l'île on a des informations sur
la législation et cetera sur les peines
soumise aux marrons mais en revanche on
n'a pas du tout d'informations sur par
exemple les rites funéraires ou leur le
savoir faire architectural donc là que
le gip est reportée ce ca formation en
donnant des preuves matérielles du
phénomène en démontrant l'existence du
grand marronnage à la taille de la
réunion est également en infirmant ou
confirmant les hypothèses historique
donc par exemple en 2011 et en 2012 on a
étudié un site qui s'appelle la vallée
secrète dont qui se situe à cilaos dans
les cirques de cilaos à plus de 2000
mètres d'altitude
donc c'était assez très difficile
d'accès qui a été choisi justement pour
son inaccessibilité et sa totale
dissimulation donc ce site on a pu
mettre en évidence deux cabanes
construites en pierre sèche dans
lesquels on a découvert des restes de
foyers où les esclaves ont fui des
pétrels de barau douce est une espèce
d'oiseaux endémiques à la réunion qui
niche à une période très particulière de
l'année et elle revient systématiquement
à cet endroit à la même période
donc ce que ce qu'on a pu conclure c'est
que les esclaves avaient une
connaissance accrue du milieu naturel de
la réunion des ressources disponibles
dans durant l'année à quel moment et
qu'ils avaient l'intention de revenir à
cet endroit là plusieurs fois puisqu'ils
sont construits de manière pérenne les
cabanes en pierres sèches et non pas en
matériaux périssables
donc évidemment l'archéologie du
marronnage en est à ses débuts à la
réunion il faudra beaucoup d'autres
recherches archéologiques pour définir
de manière plus approfondie l'ensemble
des stratégies d'adaptation des esclaves
marrons à l'avenir